[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one of
[Applause]
go easy on us adele yeah the powerhouse
singer sure knows how to turn up
on thursday adele made a surprise
appearance at a london club
surprising the crowd at a bar called
heaven and we gotta say it looks like it
was an absolutely heavenly experience
please
please welcome on stage
the singer hit the stage to help judge
the club's porn idol competition which
you can figure out the concept of on
your own
[Applause]
cheryl wasn't the only one who got in a
little face time with the diva here's
adele chatting with fans and posing for
pictures
and when she wasn't snapping selfies
adele was living it up in the club check
her out letting loose to a remix of katy
perry's i kissed a girl
you can even see the rolling in the deep
singer singing along to what the dj is
spinning
the owner of the club summed up the
night perfectly quote dreams do come
true
how come we both become a persian of a
person we don't even like
[Music]
we're in love with the world but the
world just wants to bring us down
adele's big night out caps a big week
for the star she performed and won at
the brit awards i'm very proud of myself
for sticking to my guns and putting out
an album that was about something so
personal to me
because not many people do stuff like
that anymore then she sat down for a
rare interview on the graham norton show
i want a baby next year
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the songstress pulled out some of her
signature humor during the chat and
spoke about having to put her planned
vegas residency on hold i tried my
hardest right i really thought i would
be able to pull something else together
you know in time and that was why it was
so last minute which you know i regret
obviously that i kept going with it
until that late in the day
um but it was it just wasn't ready so
while we all wait to see adele perform
in vegas we'll just keep replaying these
videos from the club
[Applause]
you